I recorded now. Hello, everybody. It is the 31st of July, going into August, 2019. We're going to
start off our Zoom call immediately with some questions that came in and hopefully address
these first. So the first question that came in was one that was emailed to us. And again, if you have
questions, make sure you email them within the subject line, put Zoom question, and we hope to get
them answered on the Zoom calls. So the question was, can you use immunotherapy for endometrial
carcinoma cancer? The answer is yes, it has been approved. So let's, we've talked about immune,
cancer immunotherapy on several other podcasts. But the cancer immunotherapy, again, is using a
new type of drug. Their key truda is the one I listed here. But there are several different brands
of these drugs that target different receptors. So remember, cancer cells are your own cells. So your
immune system really is meant to not, not attack your own cells. That's part of the issue in why
cancer continues to grow. And your immune system doesn't destroy it. A person's immune system can
be disabled. A person's immune system can be diminished to have a person's own steroids. It can
diminish their immune system. A person can be unearned or a lot of stress diminishing their immune system.
But each one of your cancer cells have a receptor. It will go too deep into it, but
that this PE1 receptor basically turns off your immune response. It turns off your T cells.
Well, the new immunotherapy drugs that are kind of exciting are drugs that attach to that receptor
so that your T cells don't get turned off by the cancer cells and the T cells will then attack the
tumor cells. Well, again, this presupposes that a person has a healthy T cell response. So doing
a lot of alternative things that will stimulate an immune response is still paramount in having
an immunotherapy drug work well for a person. Now, they've done a lot of studies on these
immunotherapy drugs and they don't work well for a lot of different cancers. So they're only approved
for certain cancers and they're in clinical trials for other cancers. So we hear a lot of people say,
I want to get into a clinical trial. I want to get into a clinical trial. Well, clinical trial is
just using a drug on your particular cancer that hasn't necessarily either worked in the past
or worked in combination with something else and that's what the trial is about or it has never
been tested on your type of cancer and that's what a clinical trial is. So ketruda is one that you
hear advertised on television a lot because it's going to prove a few years ago for several different
cancers, colon cancer and several others. Well, it's now been approved for endometrial cancers
well and it can be beneficial. Now, we've spoken about the negative effects of these drugs too because
they're turning off your immune ability to recognize self-cells. So the side effects of
immunotherapy drugs is that you're going to attack a lot of self-tissue. So you're going to end up
with autoimmune disorders based upon this drug is turning off your self-cells ability to protect
themselves against itself against your own immune system. So that's the side effect of immunotherapy
drugs. Now, still, if you got a cancer that's growing, you know, just completely relentless using
immunotherapy drugs and slowly that growth down, you could deal with the side effects with some other
ways, different medication, different natural ways to deal with this autoimmune reaction that you have.
Most common autoimmune reaction right off the bat is colitis. A person can have very bloody
stools, a lot of stools per day. In fact, they're gut when we can do some things that can really help
that and counteract that if you choose to use this medication. So yes, you can use immunotherapy
drugs for endometrial. I do believe that is that can't be the first line though. You have to have
failed chemotherapy before you'll do that. Some oncologists might be able to bypass that if they
think that you're more of a likely candidate for it. Now, they do specific genetic testing to see
if it'll even work with your cancer because they have to have a biopsy of the cancer that tests
for NMR and deficiency of defects in certain genes. Otherwise, it won't work. It's improving
that to work. So that's one caveat that they will have to test. Other question came in as are
are there long-term negative effects of using DMSO zigspray? Well, side effects, you can google
side effects of DMSO. It includes skin reactions, dry skin, headaches, dizziness, obviously it's absorbed,
drowsiness, nausea, vomiting, diarrhea, constipation. Now, these are side effects of somebody who's
dosing themselves with DMSO and there are even people that take it orally. So understand that.
When you're using a little bit of DMSO spray, a few sprays of this DMSO zigspray that we created for you
on you, we've never had anybody have any of those symptoms. Now, the most common side effect of DMSO
is a garlic-like taste in your mouth. If you've never gotten a garlic-like taste in your mouth,
after you're using DMSO, there's no way you're going to get any of those other side effects
because that would be the first effect of taking DMSO. You could get that garlic taste in your mouth
because of the, it's dyed methyl sulfoxide. It's the sulfur in the DMSO that actually gives you
that taste. So if you're not even getting that or your breath or a body order of a garlicky,
sulfur-y taste, then there's no way you're going to have side effects of the ones that are above
that line. So really, we're using DMSO in this case as the driver of the zig. So there's more to
zinc liquid zinc in there than there is DMSO. We're using the DMSO as just the driver of the zig to
help you absorb zinc through the skin, particularly right over a cancer because zinc,
cancer, cancer doesn't like zinc and it could help displace the copper. And copper is necessary
for growth. So any increased metabolism, any increased growth of cells, any laydown of new cells,
needs copper. So the whole idea of the DMSO zig spray is let's use DMSO as the driver to get the zig
into the tissue where the cancer is. So it'll displace the copper, change that ratio at the cancer
site, that zinc to copper ratio is going to be higher and it'll decrease growth by the new cells
won't have copper in order for them to continue to replicate. That's the idea of the zig spray.
So it's not the DMSO really that we're going after, that's just the driver of the zinc.
Okay, so we don't have a lot of time today because I have an interview that I have to do. So
open it up for questions and then we will leave it at that. No questions? Great. Continue to post your
questions on our email. You guys are doing that and post your questions on our Patreon or Facebook page
because that's the fastest way to get questions answered. Thank you so much and we will be back next
week. Make sure you listen to the interview that I had that we posted as a blog post. We got a lot
of really good response on that interview that was with central oil interview but I was talking
not just about a central oil but really on a lot of things of what we do here and how we tie that
together. We got a very positive response to that. All right, thank you very much.